Lee Chun Tong a Chinese blogger goes
online whenever he can he says it's
important for him to stay in contact
with his readers and for his dedication
Lee has received a 2013 Bob award for
the best blog worldwide was young it's
not the prize that's important it's the
chance to meet like-minded people people
who give me hope toilet in his blog Lee
Chun Tong writes about everyday problems
in China but the online activist doesn't
just right he also investigates those
problems Lee Chun Tong is one of six Bob
winners this year other awards went to
the most innovative bloggers and to a
blog that teaches people how to track
their digital history online the Chinese
government routinely blocks Lee's blog
he says his telephone conversations are
bugged like many Internet activists in
China Lee says he lives in constant fear
or young gaza thug I tried to teach my
readers that a person's individual
rights are more important than trying
the so-called national interests I
believe the Chinese dream is a dream of
freedom Lee Chun pong fights for his
people's freedoms every day and the Bob
gives Lee official recognition for his
dream of freedom